I always say when it's crazy TV it's
really bad for us so that means a lot of
stress with a cat's butt okay Kyle
Richards giving et a little taste of
what's to come on it season nine I know
we'll have to wait to watch to really
find out everything but can you shed a
little light on what the hell is going
on with Vanderpump that's a question you
have to ask her I don't want my words
twisted in any way shape or form all I
know is you know you know I love Lisa
we've been friends for many years we
started the show together we're the two
last original you know left from the
cast and you know I love her you know
and if she needs to take her time too
you know step away for whatever reason
you know all I know is you know we've
all reached out to her we've all
included her you know wanted her to be
there - included no it's the balls of
her part I guess you know how does her
action make you feel are you
disappointed confused I'd like her to be
around because you know selfishly you
know I like being Lisa we have fun and
we laugh together so yeah I'd like her
to be there I always I always wanted to
do the shot with Lisa when was the last
time you in her spoke recently
I mean you Rinna Erica have all kind of
taken it upon yourselves to come back at
people in the comments on Instagram to
be like that's not the story that's not
a story there's stories about you know
that we have an invite or we have an
included or
invited everything so like no no that's
not what's happening here so you feel
the need to defend yourself when you
hear stories like that so or comments we
won't like where are they getting this
bum that's not true that didn't happen
sometimes we can't resist
clapping back what can I say I know you
guys are headed out on a girls trip soon
information do you expect Vanderpump to
show up on that girl's trip I was in her
court still had to describe the upcoming
season with one word and it can't be
drama or dramatic what would it be
unpredictable so unpredictable and
I mean that's not the word unpredictable
really then like twists and turns like
every day I don't know what's coming
next
I really don't none of us do you still
feel that way as you are wrapping up
filming yes I've never felt like that
through a season so it's been strange
you know just like you just don't know
what it's gonna be around the next
corner feel like the seasons gonna end
on that note or do you think it'll be
wrapped up I don't know I'd like to see
some resolution yeah just some of the
things that are going on I think we'll
have some resolution with some and some
I don't know I have to wait for the
reunions if they show up it's going to
be a crazy season what can I say we are
here celebrating the opening of rebadged
first la boutique
are you picking out some bags to rebuild
your collection with yesterday because I
was scared my favorite would be picked
over I actually you know I big lover of
handbags
I was burglarized in December and they
stole all my handbags so you know
because if a kid knows like I don't know
if I can replace these things and now
little by little I am I love path ERT
found when she wanted to take home it
looks like I loved seeing you two out
together I know things were a little
rocky for a bit but it looks like back
on good terms
family's family so they have their
moments where we're no different than
anybody else and now we're good and
we're happy thank God goodness the
holidays